yeah a thousand eleven to get down to
twelve thirteen i gotta get a thirteen
fourteen fifteen
i gotta go to sixteen daughter seventeen
eighteen yep eighteen nineteen now two
thousand dollars back it up i got a two
grand you're out theo yep two grand i
gotta
get a chance out twenty one to get up
now one shot now two two two two bigger
double twenty
don't know right now i don't know right
now three thousand on the way my mama
one attendant
all done i have salt 2400 buyer number
sean
too late sir you're out and so is the
the sound that you're making spanky is
that the is that the uh
ring guy is that the guy in the ring yes
okay yes so he's just telling him
another bit is coming out yes
okay yeah so we just go up every time i
hear him yell
wow i only have to see him and it's
exciting for the crowd you know you got
some guy down here yelling what the hell
you know like is there is some of that
actual words is it it started off
it started off as real words uh or
actual words um you know you start off
with a basic chant and then it
kind of translates into something much
faster and you kind of shorten it
and you just kind of make it your sound
okay your change so
my chan my chance started at is uh would
he give
would he give would he give what would
he give would he give
two grand twenty more mom a month to two
to two but they would have a two and a
two and a three and a three and a four
and a five and five
now five hundred another round but
everybody now five hundred right now six
hundred right now seven another
everybody now seven seven seven would it
give what to give what to give but it
just it it
speeds up into something over over time
and practice yeah interesting
mine started off as uh bit him and get
him and get him and bit him
wow and looking heavy out the gate which
was my father's champ
oh really my father's chat was better
them and get them and get them a bit of
them and
i'm gonna get them how do you know when
to differentiate between a bid you're
seeing on the floor and a bid that's
that you are getting sent up to you from
the ring
it i mean you're both seeing the same
thing
so you're both on the same wavelength
and if the bit let's say the bid starts
at 10 grand and there's eight people
down there just
just bid and bid and bidding you'll go
from ten one
two two and a half five you'll jump it
up to two and a half five seven and a
half
eleven eleven two and a half five seven
half 12. i mean it you know you you you
read
you read the crowd like that just like
just like you do it gets exciting huh
it's very exciting
fast space too i think people like just
hearing people count remember they had
that um
you know especially where i'm from dude
if somebody could count how you thought
they were doing damn magic you know
uh i mean half my neighborhood couldn't
count yeah you know what i'm saying we
have people you told them about 11 they
didn't know what you're talking
about
you know what i'm saying yeah like after
10 they thought it had something to do
with satan you know it was real
just kind of novice numerical types you
know oh yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one